what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and of course
spider-verse and today it looks like we
have even more evidence that suggests
that andrew garfield is not done playing
spider-man and could appear in other
spider-man movies possibly his own or
could perhaps even come back to the mcu
obviously fans have been wanting this
for some time now even before spider-man
no way home came out fans were still
hoping to get an amazing spider-man 3.
but after no way home came out and
andrew garfield kind of had a redemption
arc in that movie a lot of fans have
really been pushing for sony to make the
amazing spider-man 3 there was even a
big petition for it and andrew garfield
actually said that he was open to it he
was open to play more spider-man and now
spider-man knowing home is actually back
in theaters with the extended cut and
they added a lot of new scenes to the
movie and one of those scenes actually
hints at andrew garfield returning to
play more spider-man whether that's in
the sony spider-verse or again with tom
holland spider-man in the mcu and of
course not to mention this is also a
hint that toby maguire might not be done
as well in the spider-man no way home
the more fun stuff version we can see
andrew garfield spider-man talking to
the other two expressing how he would
like to reunite with his fellow peter
parkers in this scene andrew garfield's
peter 3 talks to toby maguire's peter 2
and he says we should do this again in
which toby maguire's spider-man replies
you got it and you can see that right
here oh he's back in theaters who's
coming with me catch it on the big
screen
with new footage
[Applause]
we should do this again you got it
spiderman no way home rated pg-13
now if you haven't seen the spider-man
no way home the more fun stuff version
it is in theaters right now so you want
to go see it before it leaves theaters
again but this scene right here is
actually very curious to me it sparks my
curiosity that they included this scene
back in the extended version now we know
that sony had particular plans with
their spider-verse moving forward but
when spider-man no way home came out it
was such a major success that some of
those plans actually changed and shortly
after the success of spider-man no way
home a lot of the insiders started
talking about andrew garfield returning
for a more prominent role in sony
spider-verse and toby maguire returning
as well for some cameos or possibly a
role in a movie here or there and now
sony went ahead and included this scene
and the more fun version this particular
scene that shows andrew garfield
spider-man saying that he wants to
reunite with the other spider-man again
and toby maguire spider-man saying
absolutely you got it i find that pretty
coincidental especially if you consider
the fact that it does kind of seem like
sony has a new plan for their
spider-verse especially with madame webb
coming out now in the comics madame webb
really explores the multiverse she's a
cosmic entity and if they're going to go
that same route in their sony
spider-verse that means that the
multiverse is about to get even bigger
this definitely opens the door up for
andrew garfield spider-man to return for
toby maguire spider-man to return and
others to return as well and be
introduced and be main characters like
spider-gwen miles morales spider-man
2099 there's a whole bunch of potential
here however that's just the sony
spider-man universe there is still a lot
that can happen in the mcu actually not
too long ago only a few months ago there
was a report that andrew garfield had
actually signed a new deal to play
spider-man for multiple films and one of
those was even rumored to be secret wars
now not too long after that the official
avengers secret wars movie was announced
so it looks like the possibility for
andrew garfield's spider-man actually
coming back to the sony universe and the
mcu is looking better and better and
honestly i would be kind of shocked if
we didn't see toby and andrew both show
up in secret wars i mean we already saw
him in no way home secret wars is going
to be all about incursions and variants
of all of the characters that we already
know and hopefully a lot that we don't
know as well i really would be shocked
if we didn't see andrew and toby both
show up for secret wars but now it's
looking better than ever especially with
this scene from spider-man no way home
the more fun stuff version with andrew
garfield spider-man saying that he would
like to meet up with the other two again
hopefully this means we are one step
closer to seeing andrew garfield back in
a spider-man suit and hopefully the
amazing spider-man eventually does get
made after all i'm pretty sure sony saw
that petition and i know andrew garfield
is down so fingers crossed but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
what would you like to see happen from
andrew garfield please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things related to
spider-man and the mcu for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you